that was a different kind of football
yeah they called it back people feeling
so tense and
uneasy i think sports is a really
welcome welcome to you
yes it is welcome to cbs this morning
you already know what we're starting
with it's a sprint to the finish for
both presidential candidates on this
last day
before the election president trump is
scheduled to hold
five rallies in four keyed four key
battleground states
former vice president biden will be in
two states today ohio and pennsylvania
the long lines have not deterred an
historic early turnout
it's estimated more than 94 million
americans
have already cast their ballots tensions
are rising before election day the fbi
is investigating after a pro-trump
convoy surrounded a biden campaign bus
in texas and in north carolina officers
used pepper spray against a group of
demonstrators
that included children at a rally to
promote voting
police said they were blocking the
roadway ben tracy is following the final
countdown ben good morning
good morning so president trump will
spend the entire day on the road holding
those five rallies his final one
late tonight in michigan that's also
where he held his final rally back in
2016
and with the president still trailing in
the polls he continues to sow doubts
about the outcome of the election
we're going to have a big victory at his
final rally in florida the president
sounded confident
surrounded by thousands of supporters
who did not seem to mind that it
stretched well past midnight
president trump held five rallies in
five states sunday
and he's banking on a surge of support
on election day
when you see what's going to happen with
the great red
wave but he continues to demand to know
a winner
on election night we should know the
result of the election on november 3rd
the evening of november 3rd
that's the way it's been and that's the
way it should be
but that's not true votes have regularly
been counted after election day
in 2016 nearly 10 percent of all votes
were counted after the election
and this year it's a scenario that's
especially not guaranteed
given record voter turnout in a record
surge of mail-in ballots due to the
pandemic
more democrats tend to vote early and
those votes could take longer to count
many states can't even start counting
those votes until election day
and while mr trump is now denying
reports that he may declare victory
before an official result is known
that was the false report we'll look at
what happens
he's signaling that his campaign is
ready to challenge election results
we're going to go in
the night up as soon as that election is
over we're going in with our lawyers
both former vice president biden and his
running mate hit back
my response is the president's not going
to steal this election
well first of all we plan to decisively
win this election
so i don't think we're going to need to
get to that point
president trump will now spend election
night here at the white house after
scrapping plans for a party at his
nearby hotel the president
was not happy that washington d.c limits
indoor gatherings to 50 people
the white house sits on federal land so
those rules don't apply here
and the new york times says the
president plans to gather hundreds of
people in the east room
of the white house tony all right ben
thank you very much